je suis normal je suis un enfant
ordinaire je suis normal
je suis un enfant comme les autres
papa je veux pas monter la tente
j'arrête
tu n'en parle pas
écoute je sais que la journée était dur
mais je voudrais te montrer quelque
chose d la part de ma main
hilaire des questions que j'ai toujours
voulu te poser paul
sur qui je suis
comment tu t'appelles moi c'est
christiane à
c'est vraiment débile comme d'en avoir
une tronche si craignos ça donne pas le
droit d'être ré conquis ses entrées et
voyez le temps je regarde son chien
ça prend un verre chez pas l'âge de
boire y a pas d'âge pour se faire
plaisir enfin
petit et à vrai dire c'est par l'afrique
maintenant
paul faire braquage à l'est
[Musique]
ici tu n'as pas avoir honte
l'offre publique ce qui peut voir au
pourquoi que l'enfance le monde va pas
nous faire de cadeaux 17
alors auteur avoir un peu d'indulgence
envers de même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]